FITZ: Hi, we're back.
I'm Fitz.
BEN: And I'm Ben.
And we're here to talk with
some women about women in
technology and entrepreneurship.
FITZ: And entrepreneurship.
And here on my left--
what's your name?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Hi, I'm
Mary Himinkool.
FITZ: Mary, and you
work at Google.
Tell me a little bit about
what you do at Google.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Sure, thanks.
So I'm head of global
entrepreneurship at Google.
Our team looks after all of
Google's programs and
partnerships to support
start-ups and entrepreneurs
around the world.
FITZ: So that sounds like
you do a lot of travel.
MARY HIMINKOOL: I do.
I love the airplane.
FITZ: So what are some of the
biggest challenges that you
see as part of that job?
MARY HIMINKOOL: There are
a lot of opportunities.
You know, our mission
is to impact
start-ups across the world.
We have projects live
in 25 countries.
We work both with global
partners like Start-Up Weekend
and local partners in different
cities to try to
help further the ecosystem.
FITZ: And so you work in a
lot of different areas.
I'd like to ask you to start
out by telling us, what are
some of the things you
do in women and
technology inside of Google?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Sure,
absolutely.
So within Google we really
believe in fostering a culture
of diversity and inclusion where
we welcome different
perspectives.
We try to operate as a global
company but really focus on
cultivating local culture
within the company.
And so, we have actually
an employee resource
group, Women at Google.
And there are 4,000 women across
Google globally, 30
different chapters.
And we focus on fostering
innovation within Google and
then externally outreach into
the community as well.
FITZ: So it's building these
communities of women at Google
to help each other out and
to support each other?
MARY HIMINKOOL: To support one
another and then to also
promote diversity among our user
base and to interact with
the community as well.
So for example, we're working
right now with Women 2.0.
Who--
Sepi is here with us today.
And they're a great
partner of ours.
BEN: Well, let's introduce--
I'm sorry.
You said your name is Sepi?
SEPI NASIRI: Sepi Nasiri, yes.
BEN: Great.
And what do you do?
SEPI NASIRI: I head the global
partnership, sponsorships, and
events at Women 2.0 so I
do everything offline.
BEN: Great.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about Women 2.0?
SEPI NASIRI: Sure.
Our mission is to help increase
the number of female
founders in technology
start-ups.
And we do that online by telling
their stories and
offline by creating networking
events and conferences where
they can get together and talk
about entrepreneurship.
BEN: Great.
So then the two of you have
worked together in the past
then, I assume, at
some of these?
MARY HIMINKOOL: We have
and we're working
together today as well.
BEN: Wonderful.
So I'm curious about your
experience as an entrepreneur,
a female entrepreneur, how
did you get into this
in the first place?
What's the background
story here?
SEPI NASIRI: The ingredients is,
you have amazing parents
who are entrepreneurs as well.
So when I grew up I was able
to experience what it looks
like to be an entrepreneur.
Particularly my dad.
And now, everyone in the family
is entrepreneurs as
well, my brothers.
And today when you look at
it, you're able to study
entrepreneurship.
So things have changed
quite a bit.
I started in the publishing
and then came to Silicon
Valley, fell in love
with technology,
and here I am today.
FITZ: Mary, how did you
get to where you are?
I mean, is there a class for
studying to become head of
global entrepreneurship
at Google?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Definitiely
a lesson on the job.
But I studied at Stanford
here in Silicon Valley.
I actually studied sociology
and international policy.
I was very fascinated by
opportunities, particularly in
emerging markets.
I spent some time in Bangkok
there interning at the United
Nations and never thought
I would actually work in
technology, but then became
fascinated with technology as
that platform for actually
furthering development and
growing the internet economies
as a way towards development.
And so now it's a privilege
and pleasure to work with
entrepreneurs, developers,
students, globally and try to
help further and empower the
next generation to be
successful.
FITZ: So that's a good segue
to the next thing I want to
talk to you about.
So you're working with these
entrepreneurs globally and
everything.
Tell me a little bit about how
Google is working with these
external entrepreneurs,
including Sepi and Women 2.0.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Sure.
So track one for us is really
focused on partnerships.
So how do we work with
like-minded organizations to
help further their footprint
and help them scale?
So Women 2.0, for
example, has a
fantastic series of programs.
We like to figure out how to
incorporate Google tools and
technologies where they
can be helpful.
The second bucket is really
focused around Google programs
where we can impact the
community directly.
So we have a pilot we're running
right now in India, in
Singapore, and in Russia
called Women
Entrepreneurs on the Web.
And it's basically a program to
get thousands of women on
the web using 10 Google products
to help build and
scale and market their
businesses.
We've been really fascinated
by this.
It's basically those products.
But then women come together at
Google offices to receive
hands on training.
And what we've found is that
connecting people online is
certainly very important.
But connecting them offline and
building that community is
equally as important.
FITZ: Getting that high
bandwidth face to face
conversation.
MARY HIMINKOOL: Absolutely.
And having access to that
infrastructure of mentors who
have failed and succeeded
and can help
you is really critical.
FITZ: Maybe you guys want to
talk a little bit about
mentors, actually.
BEN: I was going to say, yeah.
So what sort of challenges have
you encountered as an
entrepreneur and have you had
mentors to work with?
SEPI NASIRI: As a female
entrepreneur, I think it's
quite hard to find mentors.
Not just because there aren't
enough female entrepreneurs
who could be mentors but
sometimes they don't feel that
they have enough time or they
have the skill set.
And so I think one way Google
is helping out with that is
recognizing who in their own
community or within Google is
able to give those mentorships
to the outside as well.
BEN: And so does Women 2.0, does
that actually help create
mentorships?
Have you experienced
that or seen that
happen within the group?
SEPI NASIRI: Sure.
One way we initiate that is with
our networking event, our
Founder Fridays, where we put
some spotlight on female
entrepreneurs who are successful
and with expressing
how they have become
successful.
Today they are actually
mentoring the next generation
of entrepreneurs.
BEN: That's great.
Go ahead.
FITZ: I want to come back
to one thing you said.
You were talking about bringing
women entrepreneurs
into Google offices and helping
them use Google Apps
and that sort of thing
to make this happen.
Can you give me example?
What's something that's really
helpful that we're teaching
folks and entrepreneurs
out there?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Sure.
So we have a program called
Get Your Business Online.
So in India, for example,
that would be Get
India Business Online.
So this is for folks in small
businesses who do not yet have
a web presence, which is a huge
challenge for a lot of
small businesses.
So getting them set up with a
free website, free domain
hosting for a year.
And then plugging into other
Google tools, Google+ for
example, leveraging the maps and
geo tools and making sure
they're able to get
up and running
as quickly as possible.
FITZ: OK.
And if they want to use other
tools that aren't
Google, it's still OK.
But we're helping them use
the Google tools, right?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Absolutely.
We want to promote businesses
getting online, leveraging the
best tools on the internet.
We obviously have more
expertise on our own platforms.
But one amazing tool has been
Google+ Hangouts, actually.
And the ability to connect and
do remote mentorship, for
example, over Google+ Hangouts
with entrepreneurs from around
the world has been really
exciting to watch.
FITZ: You said there wasn't
a class for how
to do what you do.
It was a lot of on
the job training.
Did you have mentors that
were helpful for you?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Most
definitely.
Lifelong mentors throughout.
Starting with, certainly, my
parents and a lot of amazing
entrepreneurs and colleagues
along the way.
Everybody has been
super helpful.
So I think that's the one
critical thing is don't be
afraid to ask questions, ask
for help, ask for advice.
All inputs are welcome.
And then you kind of pick
and glean your lessons.
FITZ: And I think Ben and I
both have had some very
influential mentors
in our time.
BEN: I think it's interesting
that both of you have had
parents as mentors to sort
of get into this area.
One of the things I was talking
about earlier with you
was just the issue of being a
woman in this space and if
there are challenges
specific to that.
Walk up to somebody and say,
yes, I'm an entrepreneur.
I start companies.
And do you get strange reactions
because you're a
woman in this space?
Has that happened?
SEPI NASIRI: Not really because
I never look at myself
as a woman.
I'm looking at myself as an
entrepreneur or a founder or a
technologist, whatever l am.
And so going into a room, I'm
not looking at victimizing
myself, I'm looking at
empowering myself.
So empowering yourself is
looking at my resources,
looking at my network, and who
can help me succeed instead of
looking at my shortcomings.
BEN: Have you seen that to be
a problem with other people
you've worked with, where they
see themselves as a victim?
SEPI NASIRI: I don't
want to say victim.
But they look at the
shortcomings and the negative
instead of the positive.
There's always ways to improve
yourself by looking at where
are your resources?
What is available to you today
in educating yourself before
you step forward and do the
next step, whether it's in
building a product or a
service or going to an
interview or pitching your
company for funding?
BEN: So it really is
about attitude is
what it sounds like.
FITZ: Yeah, it sounds
a lot like you're
saying, it's attitude.
It's giving yourself permission
to be awesome.
SEPI NASIRI: Yes, definitely.
BEN: So I'm curious about what's
going on at Google I/O
related to women
in technology.
FITZ: You want to talk
about that Mary?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Sure.
So, a couple of exciting
things.
Last night we kicked off with
a pre-I/O event called Women
Tech Makers at I/O. We had a
couple hundred women at the
Google San Francisco office.
And we had a panel of Google
female executives actually
sharing some of their
experiences in leadership,
product innovation, and how
to foster a culture of
empowerment within a company.
So that was fantastic.
And on Friday morning, day three
at 9:00 AM, Sepi and I
will actually both be on a
panel, which is called
Designing For The Other Half:
Sexy Isn't Always Pink.
And that'll be more of an
exploration of the product
business landscape.
And how to design and market
products for everyone,
thinking about inclusion.
So 9:00 AM on Friday.
FITZ: 9:00 AM on Friday.
And that will wind up
on YouTube after
I/O as well, right?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Absolutely.
It will.
FITZ: So let's talk about
pink for a second.
So that's a typical thing.
We're going to take a product
that's for the general public
and make it pink.
And then it's called the
product for women.
What do you guys feel
about that?
SEPI NASIRI: Well, I think
colors are important.
I mean even if you look at
Google's colors there are lots
of different shades.
Women 2.0's is hot
pink, actually.
I think it's catchy.
But would I wear it every day?
Probably not.
But I think it's an
amazing color.
It's just an attitude
as well with that.
So not every product has to
be pink to be sexy or
appealing to women.
BEN: What have you learned
about designing
products for women?
What are some of the wisdom
you've picked up?
SEPI NASIRI: Well I think women
design products that are
a solution to a problem.
So it could be any
color, actually.
Most likely the solution they
haven't found when they go out
and look for it.
So what they did is say, OK.
I can be the person
designing it.
And it works.
It sells.
FITZ: You told me an amazing
statistic before-- and this is
something good for everybody
watching this to listen--
that people who are early
adopters of a lot of the new
technology there are women.
And can you talk about
that please?
SEPI NASIRI: Well, I
think it's 80% of
consumers today have--
and they're women-- who
have purchasing power.
Whether you are an office
manager or HR or you're the
entrepreneur, we are controlling
the money.
So we are going to also
to make the decision.
It's great to have women who
are designing for women and
the general public when they
have that idea of what is the
next best thing.
BEN: I guess if I were designing
a game or an Android
app or something, is there a
mistake I might make that is a
common mistake that might make
it difficult for women to want
to purchase that
kind of thing?
SEPI NASIRI: If it's
not user-friendly
for the women, obviously.
We have different
responsibilities, for example,
if we have kids.
So if it's a gadget that is not
working for me to have a
small purse or a big purse or
it doesn't fit in certain
ways, then yes.
Then you're missing out
on that particular
demographic or market.
BEN: Interesting.
FITZ: So Mary do you want to
maybe talk a little bit about
that, about designing products
more for women or more
accessible?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Sure.
I think it's about designing
for inclusion, really, and
just understanding and listening
to feedback from
your user base, right?
Regardless of gender or
demographic or where they're
coming from globally.
It's really about, how do you
solicit that user feedback and
how do you incorporate it
and continue to test?
So I think of it more from an
inclusive perspective than
targeting any one specific
. gender.
FITZ: To come back to what you
talked about earlier about
working internally at
Google, to be more
inclusive for women.
What are something that
entrepreneurs or people who
keep starting small companies
could do to do that?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Absolutely.
So I think it's about building
the culture from the bottom
up, from the top down,
every direction.
Really promoting flexibility
within the workplace and
leading by example.
So really facilitating
leadership training among
women within the company and
bringing them together as a
community to help support
one another, too.
BEN: Wonderful.
I think we got to wrap
it up here guys.
So thank you very much.
FITZ: Yeah, did you guys have
any sort of parting
things you want to--
BEN: Parting comments?
FITZ: Parting recommendations
or comments?
MARY HIMINKOOL: Yeah, just
that we're really
excited to be here.
We're excited about the
opportunities in technology
for both men and women.
And we hope you tune into
the panel on Friday.
FITZ: Friday at 9 o'clock.
BEN: Great.
Alright.
Thank you very much.
FITZ: Thanks a lot.
Bye.